- So former officer Derek
Chauvin was convicted
and he was convicted on
three different counts.
And I've gotten so many questions
about how can a criminal
defendant be convicted
of three different crimes
based on the same conduct.
- [Judge] Find the defendant guilty.
- Here Chauvin was convicted
of second degree murder,
which in Minnesota is the
felony murder statute.
Then you have murder in the third degree.
And finally, second degree manslaughter.
Chauvin will not serve
jail related to all three.
The constitution prohibits
double punishment
for the same crime.
Chauvin will only serve time
related to the most serious offense
because that's the one that
carries the most jail time.
So now you know next
time I see you in court.